president biden's administration will
not directly acknowledge what numbers do
indicate
is a massive surge in big city violence
and the legislation promised in the wake
of
the floyd death is still unsettled and
undetermined
white house correspondent peter ducey
has that part of the story tonight live
from the north lawn good evening peter
good evening brett we have a late
breaking update about that legislation
from the president himself he talked to
reporters while he was walking out to
marine one for a flight
to a friend's funeral in delaware he
says he doesn't want to negotiate
through the press but he has spoken to
the lawmakers negotiating
the police reform bill in the congress
and
in an admission of a missed deadline
he says he now expects progress on it
after
memorial day
one year after his death george floyd's
family members visited the white house
as a biden administration deadline to
pass a police reform bill in floyd's
honor
came and went if you can make federal
laws to protect the bird
which is the bald eagle you can make
federal laws to protect people of color
the administration is facing troubling
statistics
is there a crime problem in this country
well i would say certainly there is a
guns problem a red state governor
disputes that one thing they'd like to
talk about is guns without
recognizing that most of the gun crimes
occur in inner city situations like in
chicago
so today fox followed up homicides up
113
minneapolis up 38 in philly up 22
in chicago just to clarify the white
house's position on this
is that that is mostly because of guns
well first i'm not sure what data you're
looking at but i think what we can
most data that is out there shows that
there's actually been a rise in crime
over the course of the last year since
the start of the pandemic which
actually predates president biden taking
office to be totally clear
you're right you're right you're right
peter and that's why we're we are
focused
well we're focused on uh solutions here
republicans worry about progressive
pressure to reimagine funding
for police departments i got a text from
my mom this morning she still lives in
brooklyn new york
hi mom and she said point blank son you
were right last summer
defunding the police is only going to
hurt the inner city the reasons why
the police reform bill in progress is
delayed
aren't clear the issues are still
outstanding
they can see the finish line they are
reaching it
but they aren't there yet george floyd's
family left the white house to meet with
the senator
giving the most republican input on the
bill tim
scott as they say they're hopeful the
delayed bill
can still be bipartisan as president
biden
waits to sign it he is going to be
patient to make sure it's the right bill
not a rush bill the president also gave
us some
insight tonight about another big story
his decision
to wave sanctions on officials that
allowed the nordstream
2 pipeline from russia to germany
to continue he says that he came to that
conclusion to wade the sanctions
even though critics charge that the
pipeline project being completed
benefits russia
because he thought stopping it would be
counterproductive to
u.s european relations and he also said
that
by the time he took office the pipeline
was almost done
anyway right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else